-[Rapping] ♪ You thought Bernie
could save you, ho ♪
♪ Pay back all them dollars
I gave you, ho ♪
♪ Don't forget
this is a business ♪
♪ Keep praying
for that forgiveness ♪
♪ 20 years 'fore you finish ♪
♪ And then boom, I hit you
with that interest ♪
♪ But getting an education's
the American dream ♪
♪ And I'm that bitch,
Sallie Mae ♪
♪ I want to so some schemes ♪
♪ Do some schemes ♪
Come with a hook right there.
You say,
♪ Schools and schemes ♪
♪ Schools ♪
-Is you rapping
about student loans?
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Issa Rae.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So this is your wonderful
new show.
It is called "Rap [Bleep]."
-How are you saying it
right now?
-"Rap [Bleep]."
-Yeah, how are --
Is it going to be like
"Rap Bleep"?
-Oh, it's going to be beeped,
yeah.
We found out earlier today.
-Oh. [Bleep].
-Yeah, so they'll beep you
as well.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
-So you obviously knew
when you named the show
"Rap [Bleep]"
that this would be a problem.
-I did, yes.
I anticipated that
it was a tentative title,
and then I talked to HBO legal,
like, what can we get away with,
because we had an asterisk
in the title
and then we replaced it
with an exclamation point,
and they were like,
"It's totally fine."
Like, "TV Guide" can print that.
And so then it was like, yes,
it's out there,
but now it's on billboards
and little kids are seeing it.
And sorry, parents.
[ Laughter ]
But they can read,
which is great.
-Yeah!
They can read, that's great.
-That's so good. Yeah.
-I also feel like that's one of
those words --
what are -- kids are hearing
that at a pretty young age now.
You know?
-Kids are.
If they have great parents.
[ Laughter ]
-So you've got --
this is about two friends
who reconnect
to start rapping together.
What gave you this idea?
-I am a huge rap fan,
and this idea has kind of been
gestating for a while.
I've always wanted to have
something set
in the music world,
and this is just such
an exciting time.
Like, there's so many dope
female rappers
who are out here killing it.
And one of my favorite
producers, a male,
happened to say that all women
rap about now is, like,
their vaginas. Like,
it's all the same, all the same.
And I was like that's not fair
because men rap
about the same thing
all the time.
And so that -- that kind of
double standard
really interested me.
-Well, it's really fun because
there is sort of that
more socially, you know,
issue-oriented rap in this,
and then the other
that you mentioned.
[ Laughs ]
-Yep.
-Look, I already said
"Rap [Bleep]."
I don't want to get beeped
again.
-Like, I don't know,
I don't want to push it.
-[ Laughs ] It's really fun.
The women you've cast
are fantastic.
-They're incredible.
They're all new actresses,
for the most part.
It's a new cast,
and they're killing it.
I'm so proud of them.
-It also seems like you took it
seriously,
which as a fan,
you would have to.
If you're doing a show
about rap,
you have to have actual
good rap lyrics.
Does that mean you had to find
television writers who were good
at writing rap songs,
or did you actually also hire
rap lyricists?
-So what's great is we were able
to have a traditional
writers' room, which was,
you know, really funny,
brilliant writers.
Some of them were from Miami.
And then just to be able to
have, like, authentic rap --
like, the music has to be good.
They actually
have to be good rappers.
We got to employ some of
my favorite rap artists,
like Pineapple City, Incognita,
Dreezy,
and they wrote lyrics
for the characters.
And then we had music camps to
make music for the show.
And it was
like an intricate process.
And then, of course,
the two kind of met up.
And it was just -- it was great.
I'm really proud of the music
of the show.
-You were only behind the scenes
on this show?
-Yes, thank the Lord.
-Are you super happy?
-Oh, my God, are you kidding me?
I was writing this show while
filming season five
of "Insecure."
I was tired of being on camera.
And I was like, "Where can I --
What can I write where I can get
out of this city?" Because
I wrote it during quarantine.
I was like, "Ooh, where do
I want to be next? Ooh."
If the show gets picked up,
Miami.
And then it was just like --
I just get to be behind
the scenes and direct --
I mean, not literally direct,
but, like, as a producer,
give notes to the amazing cast
and contribute to the story.
And so, it was just --
it was a lot of fun.
It was a different muscle.
-You were still on camera
obviously in other things.
I just saw the trailer for
B.J. Novak's new movie,
"Vengeance," that I think comes
out in a couple of weeks.
Looked like a very fun trailer.
Was that a good time?
-That was a great time.
B.J. Novak is incredible.
You know I've been a fan
of his since "The Office,"
and his writing, and this is
his directorial debut.
And it's just such
a smart script.
It's like, you know, set in
the true crime podcast world,
which I'm obsessed with.
-Uh-huh.
-Which sounds terrible to say.
You know? Like, "Oh, I love
true crime murder podcasts!"
-Yeah. You're like, "Do you like
make-believe crimes?"
"No, only the true ones."
-No, I want it to be real.
I like suffering.
But it's terrible --
It's so bad.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry.
But the movie kind of explores
that in addition to,
like, truth in America now.
And it's just brilliantly done,
and I'm happy to be
a part of it.
-Well, I'm so happy
to have you here.
Thanks so much
for making it back.
It's such a delight to spend
time with you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Issa Rae! The first two episodes
of "Rap [Bleep]"
begin streaming July 21st
on HBO Max.
And "Vengeance" is in theaters
July 29th.
We'll be right back
with Nikki Glaser.